[Musique]
aux États-Unis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce film est l'histoire de Wang Hong
quand elle était petite
c'est son expérience pendant la  war and
the long est une amie chère à moi que j'ai
rencontrée il y a 15 ans en lisant son livre
m'a beaucoup parlé de ce pays donc d'une certaine manière
je fais ça pour elle pour sa famille
pour le Cambodge et beaucoup aussi depuis les
greniers donc  il apprend qui il est et
sait à qui appartiennent ce n'est
pas seulement l'histoire de ma famille, mais l'histoire d'une
nation. Je n'allais le faire confiance à
personne.
piste d'émission acoustique troodontid j'ai vu
une grande fille qui dirait que Hosea
Max travaille dessus depuis le début,
il est dans la production, il m'a aidé avec
le scénario et ce n'est pas seulement parce
qu'il est mon fils, c'est parce que ce film est à
travers le  les yeux d'un enfant et nous avons
tous dû nous ouvrir un peu plus et
être comme des enfants  Je ne veux pas voir un
enfant traverser la guerre, je voulais savoir
ce qu'un enfant ressentait et ce qu'il se concentrait
sur ce qu'il voyait,
dang chakras importants pour la mitose, c'est
mr.  DiPalma Tracy Mallory -
Discussion provisoire de Mallory Une équipe totalement asiatique
donc non Dante n'est pas une école de créatures
La toile de Thompson canto le Cambodgien
ce serait un capital si vous
ne savez rien sur le Cambodge et que vous voyez
ce film, vous ne penserez pas simplement que ce sont les
gens qui souffrent  récompense vous
penserez que ce sont des gens vraiment intéressants
leurs racines et leur personnalité
leur humour leur amour de la musique leur
culture c'est tout ça ça doit être
à la fin cette lettre d'amour au
Cambodge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]